I think Marcus no I'm coming for you my
farts coming get get into a spot and
stay there all right come for you babe I
think I blend again wait II baby wait
why did you oh wait can props not hit
this button
what can no no how do I get it here okay
that's good okay where's my silent but
deadly Fred oh you're silent big dead
things right mesial and I'm on your team
right now this is all be a prop yes
zombies of pubs eyes on my teeth you
can't even give us hints you see
anything wait Bob that's hardly fair
fight zombie Oh No hey is this where is
where is mr. zombie man oh that's where
mr. zombie man is okay you guys are so
impossibly boned you don't even
understand I know he doesn't talk or run
around probably like you do yeah exactly
he doesn't sass and he doesn't sneak her
when you guys have bananas there are
invincible bananas Wow
maybe you should shoot at him good do
that again just like that what's
happening I don't know you guys are
being fools you're so stuck in the same
area that you have no idea
well wait maybe you should shoot it if
you can't move good keep shooting yeah
just like that I kind of totally
betrayed my team raid right there but
yeah you get the point well no I could
not move because of the box there's a
barrel that I couldn't pick up Oh
so you would have just moved right on by
if I under said I would have yes I hid
inside the Tower of bear
shut up shut up it's all districts
zombie isn't fooled by that zombie baby
staring at a corner were you a better
baby did you need to be put in timeout
like work out what you were just trying
to use my location to look at the first
floor where I saw you both you were
behind the office loser oh wait a minute
no oh oh no that was a poor choice I
lived all right get out of here wait is
that pretty good spot though right right
way it's pretty good yeah a lying sack
of crap
I am either running away from you into
the jail cells right now or I have not
moved you'll have to decide be
intimidating I don't want him looking
for me yeah the Sun the silent just
thrower you know you guys are running
around like crazy you should probably
have a drink mark no no no no no no no
no no no no we're just gonna stand here
and push this button shut up no mark why
don't you come have a drink no no no no
no no no no come have a drink like this
this is fun load off just grab grab grab
a drink no now this this button great
ear or something okay all right fine I'm
coming I'm coming for ya come come have
a drink
he's only got 5% I said that already
cuz I made a poor choice I thought a
chair was in the wrong place
Bobby died to save house in Bologna you
had no idea where I was
yeah I did what was I I don't know you
can't I oh this is bad all right mutters
let go
all right I'm cool cool it's going on
I'm cool I'm cool bruh somebody threw a
barrel in the way the jail oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no okay okay I don't
understand what mark thinks he's come on
Basilisk yeah do you think I'm lying
again I'm just finding like an idiot
usually when I scream like an idiot I'm
not not an idiot it's usually idiotic
you see what I mean I'm totally normal
totally normal completely perfect in
every way
Oh fine I grabbed one of the spines in
there for like a second and I couldn't
get it again so no idea you oh you [ __ ]
you are so dumb
Wow okay do the same thing in the other
room the other room yeah would you just
a chair in the back I don't know what he
was I have no idea oh we're hunters
again for this I get back in I can't
[Laughter]
zombie was a baby trying to bring props
to mark mark is a box god all right I'm
not comfortable with this spot but this
is what's happening now so uh huh tell
me more about this spot is it it's
really stupid oh really ad and stupid
okay right something smells weird wait a
minute
I don't know where we oh I know where we
[Applause]
tell him where you are or what you are
that I saw running across my screen oh
[Laughter]
dami be observant don't look really
carefully in there yeah wait go
perfectly timed Wade but altogether
probably phew
maybe you should be better at games than
you currently are which is awful good
good insult oh god what happened
there's a newspaper going up the stairs
that's a lie who saw what know who said
what - where'd it go it's out here does
that your liar oh you're so bad at games
oh what a loser
wait are you lying to me no I was I blow
up the barrels there was a newspaper and
he ran
stairs I don't think he ran off the
stairs I think you're getting messed
with he ran up the stairs never never I
turned around he might have left yeah
well maybe when you shouted he's feeling
a little green so he's going to uh
solitary confinement that might have
been too good a bit a bottle in the jail
cell your covers been blown
look what both Lee and then oh my
goodness gracious knows the greatest
move he's so fit even I've lost him good
lordy he's back in in the backroom where
Mark was a table died by the bleeps
jokes underneath hey no sig not fair not
fair not fair come on zombie you can
make it you can make it
[Music]